y at il plus de chiens que cha montréal
il y a environ deux fois plus de chaque
que deux chiens 330000 chat et 145 mille
chiens les montréal et font surtout
appel à leur entourage
lorsqu'ils veulent adopter un animal de
compagnie 26 % des propriétaires de
chats et 17 % des propriétaires de
chiens ont obtenu leur amour auprès d'un
ami ou d'un proche mais beaucoup les
abandonne dans les refuges ou dans les
fourrières en 2012 14 mille chiens et
chats ont été euthanasiés à montréal on
en comptait dix mille en 2013 et 8000 en
ce nombre a beaucoup baissé car la ville
affirme que les gens sont plus
sensibilisés qui a eu plus d'adoption et
d'animaux retrouvés au continuer à faire
baisser le nombre d'euthanasies
l'enregistrement des animaux a été
rendue obligatoire presque partout à
montréal mais seulement 13% des chiens
et 4% des chats possède une médaille